[Music]
today is the day we become Abbi and
Ilana the boss bitches we are in our
minds are you with me yes yes yes is
Ilana you recognize you from movies
Instagram that means so much to you
explaining is incredible Yass Yass yeah
like my friend a huge got a friend yeah
chocolate brown eyes ass is an angel I
am NOT oh mom
[Music]
I'm wild yeah if you really use some
Abbi magic there's a pube situation
somebody barf on an exercise ball and
then it bounced down two flights of
stairs Oh Abbi I love you I love you you
do too yeah you're my little cupcake
you're wearing a dog hoodie it's from
the dog owners section of arrogance your
holes for dog ears fixed at day 274 five
hours late wearing a napkin as a shirt
violently hi you druggie lesbian dudes
we breathe say vaporizer hey no pain
when you gave me a guru
[Music]
hey listen I've been there sweetie
it's my dick where's the bathroom where
is it the bathroom you're not a baby
you're man no job miss ha lady you got
thank you it's gonna smoky right that's
what she said
oh oh oh I mean you're the best roommate
when you're ready become a Susan
I like sir wide open thank you I'm
looking of America your Polly we are 5
I'm not by your right how do I know if I
haven't really tested my pen under I do
you in the ass the first night that we
did anything I think that's pretty
immature drink what is that what's up
hey you must be tray horny and that tray
anything a lot of what
am i at the farmers market coz this is
so juicy
there's no trifecta it's more of like a
duo smart and sexy she has an
unrealistic you were sweeping me off my
feet you are two lucky Jews
[Music]